je m'appelle scarlett marleau et je suis
étudiante en archéologie urbaine ici à
113 mètres de profondeur il ya une
cavité secrète qui pourraient renfermer
un élément clé de notre passé comment tu
veux qu'on y descendent les catacombes
il n'y a plus de 300 kilomètres de
galeries juste sous nos pieds les restes
de six millions de cadavres ils sont
entreposés
arrête c'est ici ils empirent de la mort
ce sont des ossements humains
on va traverser ça c'est parti les vins
tranquilles à tu coincé c'était quoi ça
je sais pas et c'est quoi elle pleure
maintenant on peut pas faire demi tour
on continue petit pas qu'on est revenue
sur nos pas c'est exactement pareil non
tout est à l'envers n'entra disparu
attendez il ya un passage
c'est pas possible
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc quand
j'étais petit j'avais un piano
exactement comme celui ci j'en jouais
tout le temps le light est cassé
c'est quoi ce cas je peux le juge
faisant d'après la mythologie c'est ce
qui est inscrit sur les portes de
l'enfer
ils marcheront sur le ventre pour entrer
au royaume des ténèbres
vous avez entendu
quelqu un qu est ce qui nous arrive à
pas
c'était pas de ma faute papa